I can end this you owe me a
dance lesson yes saturday night
Welcome back this is going to be my full marvel
what if episode 1 video there were a whole bunch
of easter eggs i'll explain what's going on with
the series and how this is all going to play out
because it is canon to the mcu so if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the episodes i am doing a giveaway for disney
plus memberships all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and just leave your favorite
moment or easter egg from the episode on the video
so careful for spoilers from the episode if you
have not seen it yet starting with the episode
title what if captain carter were the first
avenger so obviously this is all based on the
events of the first captain america movie there
were many scenes that mirrored moments from the
first captain america movie in some of the other
movies as well like the first avengers movie
ma'am please put down the sword which is a nice
easter egg for loki showing up with a scepter sir
please put the spear down there are nine episodes
total all the episode titles will follow this
naming convention what if something something you
know obviously something goes very different for
each of these characters each of these different
universes that we see during the series but the
actual episode starts just straight off with a
custom what if marvel studios intro each of the
different marvel disney plus series has gotten
their own custom version of the marvel studios
intro the one for what if starts with the regular
version of the new marvel phase 4 intro like the
other series but when it transitions to the white
text of the marvel studios logo the intro changes
to the cel-shaded animation style of the what if
episodes because it's an animated series so the
live-action title changes to animated and i know
a lot of people were wondering is this going to
cross over with the live action stuff because it's
animated and we've never seen that before they did
say that some of these animated characters
from what if from alternate universes will
eventually show up in live action like captain
carter they implied heavily that she will show
up in the live-action movies but they didn't
say which movie just that eventually she will
she's not the only one they said that any of the
characters that we see any of the big conceits the
big twists could wind up becoming live action
spin-off series by themselves is all open for
grabs there are no limits here but then it starts
with the watcher uwatu's voiceover narration kind
of like a twilight zone rod sterling intro but
his entire speech over the intro here and his
speech at the end before the end credits are all
taken directly from the original what if comics
they always open the comic book stories with the
watcher introducing the title and explaining how
everything worked what the rules were his speech
about time space reality is more than a linear
path is a prism to endless possibilities is a
reference to one the infinity stones but also too
to the multiverse because this is a big multiverse
series as that happens the frame shatters into a
bunch of shards prisms of endless possibilities
representing the alternate universes that we'll
see in the episodes the loki series just did
a version of this explaining how alternate
timelines work how the true multiverse works but
then it shows us a version of black panther in
his original civil war costume captain marvel iron
man in his infinity war armor this is party thor
the new version of thor that we'll meet during
the series this is black widow from the avengers
infinity war episode because of her blonde hair
and her special jacket that we found out about
during the black widow movie this is a version
of captain america in his civil war costume we'll
see many different iterations of the avengers
obviously in the captain carter universe she winds
up becoming part of that universe's version of
the avengers but will eventually meet an alternate
version of the avengers with steve rogers captain
america on the team so all these people that you
see in the intro here all these scenes in all the
prisms here represent actual scenes from episodes
that we'll see in the future like you see king
t'chaka here you see obadiah stain all these are
taken from upcoming episodes and because there are
so many of them that they showed during this intro
i already did a big trailer video explaining what
all these different scenes in the shards represent
in which episodes they come from so i'll post a
link for that video in the description because
it would take me like a whole 20 minutes to
explain all these different scenes by themselves
but suffice it to say all these things are from
upcoming episodes that we'll see during the series
when the watcher talks about a single choice
branching out into infinite realities and the
larger shards break into infinite ones spiraling
off into the background that's another loki
connection that's the exact same thing we saw play
out in the loki series in the loki finale with a
true multiverse breaking free from the sacred
timeline because of sylvia's choice to kill
he who remains a single choice giving birth to
infinite possibilities infinite versions of kang
when he announces himself as the watcher and
that he's watching all these things play out he
is playing the main watcher from the comics uwatu
and most of you will remember we saw live-action
versions of the watchers during guardians of the
galaxy 2 they canonized stan lee as an agent of
the watchers that's his actual formal name inside
the mcu agent of the watchers even though there
are many versions of the watchers race inside the
mcu the way they're explaining it on the series
is that it's just uwatu this one watcher the
main watcher from the 616 marvel universe comics
watching all these other alternate realities play
out all these alternate universes usually in the
comics when you go to different universes you
also meet different versions of uwatu so even
though the series is canon to the mcu and we're
just seeing one version of him there might be
other versions of uwatu out in the multiverse out
there somewhere because the episode is only about
30 minutes long and they have to cover the entire
plot of the first captain america movie they do
speed run a lot of things from that first captain
america movie so the watcher begins setting up the
events at the beginning of the first captain
america movie explaining how world war ii is
playing out and how they fast forward to steve
rogers preparing to get the super soldier serum
he starts out by explaining what happened to the
events of the original captain america movie like
the actual mcu sacred timeline the infinity saga
as we saw things play out but then introduces the
whole what if of it all what if in an alternate
universe a single choice created a whole new hero
and we travel to the captain carter universe
which they don't actually give a designation
to they just call it another earth maybe when
we get some of the show notes later the show
runners will explain to us what they're actually
calling her earth that she comes from and they
reveal that the nexus event so to speak the event
that caused everything to change was peggy carter
choosing to stay on the floor with steve rogers
while the experiment was going on just like in the
original captain america movie richard armitage's
hydra agent tries to sabotage the experiment but
does it in a slightly different way and is a
little bit more successful winds up shooting
steve rogers wounding him so badly that he won't
be able to survive the super soldier process
i love that the military's first alt choice on the
fly is to turn howard stark into a super soldier
that would be a disaster but it would be a
hilarious disaster we knew they were going to do
captain carter so of course he refuses saying that
he's there to press buttons which they pay off at
the end of the episode when peggy carter says tell
me you don't need help pressing buttons so peggy
carter grabs the remaining vial of super soldier
serum climbs in the chamber and becomes captain
carter although the way they explain it she's not
a captain when this happens that happens later in
the episode when she has them promote her to the
rank of captain so she doesn't officially become
captain carter and get her name till about halfway
through the episode and the whole idea here is
that she's basically becoming a version of captain
america yes she is wearing the union jack and she
is british army so she's kind of like captain
britain but i think the reason why they're just
calling her captain carter as her official name on
the show in the merchandise is because they want
to say the captain britain name for brian braddock
in the mcu or another character to become a more
legit version of captain britain because he comes
from the king arthur mythology which i'll mention
in a second because there's some moments at the
end of the episode which are kind of winks at that
there was a huge captain britain easter egg during
avengers endgame speak of the devil peggy carter
herself mentions agent braddock during the 1970s
when they're stealing the pym particles in the
tesseract so it sounds like eventually kevin feige
plans on introducing a version of captain britain
at some point they set up the whole rivalry with
her commanding officer who doesn't want anything
to do with her like you're not supposed to be
here we were supposed to have a real super soldier
this scene of them taking her vials of blood
is the exact same scene from the first captain
america movie they changed the order in which
some of the events from the first captain america
movie happened but most of the scenes during the
episode are scenes taken from that first captain
america movie like she starts out working the
punching bag the same way captain america did
in the post credit scene from the first captain
america movie after he'd already come back in
present day heading into the events of the first
avengers movie steve rogers jokes about her having
to do that original captain america uso tour that
he did during the first captain america movie
selling war bonds think about how terrible that
would be howard stark also makes a reference to
that later in the episode when he gives her her
captain america costume oh yeah this was going
to be for that uso tour we were going to make
you do that steve mentions bucky in the howling
commandos unit the 107 because everything up to
this point in the timeline has been the same as
it was in the original movie so bucky had already
been deployed at this point she has the exact same
problem that steve had during the original movie
with the military not letting either one of them
join the actual war until they called an audible
and disobeyed orders they said that the whole
theme of the dance from the first captain america
movie in the entire infinity saga movies because
they didn't really pay that last dance off till
avengers end game steve mentions he's a terrible
dancer peggy says you just haven't found the right
partner yet so i'm now wondering if over multiple
seasons of what if as she travels the multiverse
the guardians of the multiverse the multiverse
avengers team that will eventually form if her
arc will eventually end with a similar avengers
endgame style captain america ending where she
makes it back to her version of steve rogers in
the 1940s they have their dance and then she grows
old with him they've only confirmed what if season
two i don't know how many seasons they plan on
letting it run hopefully it'll make it to five
seasons because it seems like a pretty solid show
so far and because it's what if you can literally
do anything you want you can get as crazy as you
want because it's all about exploring the craziest
possibilities in the multiverse then like i said
they sort of changed the order from the scenes
in the original captain america movie they go to
townsburg norway where we get the version of red
skull stealing the tesseract but this time when
he takes the tesseract he also takes the entire
giant asgardian wall carving and if you
didn't remember tonsburg this town here
is also the same town from the flashback in the
first thor movie that odin went to to protect
against the frost giants it's also the place
where he died on the cliffs side and told thor
this would be a great place for asgard and it's
where they build new asgard after the asgardians
come to earth after infinity war we'll see a much
more developed version of it during the events of
thor love and thunder the wall carving itself
is designed exactly like the one in the movie
but the camera focuses on the tentacles of the
hydra foreshadowing the hydra monster that comes
through the portal later in the episode in the
serpent secret compartment with the button that
contains the actual tesseract is a representation
of the mid-guard serpent which in norse mythology
is loki's child there were a couple references to
that during the loki series but again changing the
order of the scenes from the first captain america
movie the mission that peggy disobeys and goes on
the first time is to steal the actual tesseract
from red skull in arnim zola originally in the
movies it was captain america saving bucky the
pows the hell and commandos that doesn't happen
till a little bit later in the episode this time
howard stark gives her the costume like i said
and the reason why it's the union jack is because
she's british she's part of the british army but
because we're speed running the plot of the first
captain america movie they give her a more armored
version of it like i made some upgrades to this
annie gives her the vibranium shield also with the
union jack on it they jump cut to her stopping the
hydra convoy carrying arnem zola in the tesseract
to europe using her attack as a sort of montage
that you get in a lot of superheroes stories and
movies tv shows where the hero discovers their
powers in the middle of a fight like she learns
what she can do while this is all happening like
oh wow i didn't know i was this strong she brings
the tesseract back to the u.s headquarters and
tells them to promote her to captain because
she's going on field duty to the front lines and
that's where her name captain carter comes from
howard stark gets his hands on the tesseract
way earlier than he did during the events of the
original captain america movie and his next act is
to create an iron man suit for skinny steve rogers
calling it the hydra stomper and if it wasn't
clear here he was using the tesseract to power
it like he put the actual tesseract itself inside
the suit to use like an arc reactor so he's using
an infinity stone to power the suit really cool
easter egg for iron man and present day the mcu if
you remember iron man used his father's research
on the tesseract to create his new element to use
in his new arc reactor during iron man 2. because
that element is based on infinity stones in a way
iron man's arc reactors since the events of
iron man 2 were all based on infinity stones
so almost this whole time in the mcu iron man
has been powered by an infinity stone so to speak
yes the suit does look a little bit like the
iron monger suit but that's just because he's
working with more primitive technology that was
available during world war ii in the 1940s then
they go on that mission from the first captain
america movie to say bucky the hell and commandos
it just happens later in the episode she reminds
him just like in the movie that he still owes her
that dance to just kind of continue the theme of
the dance from the first captain america film most
of this rescue is a shot-for-shot copy that plays
out exactly like the events of the first captain
america movie but like i said there's speed
running everything so it just happens way quicker
this shot of her busting through the door with
the howling commandos the same shot from the
first captain america movie just happening during
a different part of the actual story the big
difference this time though is that steve rogers
flies in wearing that iron man armor rescuing them
from the german infantry bucky instantly figures
out it's steve rogers when peggy calls out steve's
name and you may notice throughout the episode
sebastian stan was playing bucky during the
episode but he had way more quips than you would
expect from bucky the joke the sebastian stan had
when he was talking about performing his lines
is that the big twist with his version of bucky
obviously he doesn't become winter soldier that's
a twist but the bigger twist is that they made him
funny whereas the normal mcu version of bucky is
like the most serious character ever the fact that
the armor says c15 on it makes it sound like it's
the 15th version of the armor but then they do
a captain carter version of that captain america
movie montage after they rescue the howling
commandos when they just go around wrecking hydra
in german troops they also take advantage of the
suit's ability to fly doing a really cool aerial
assault it would have been cool to see something
like this during the live-action captain america
movie then they do a slightly different version
of red skull killing hitler's regular military
officers when they start yelling at him claiming
that hydra is now going to do their own thing
the way he explains that he's going to summon
the true champion of hydra from beyond the stars
as he looks at the asgardian carving here at the
symbol of the hydra so what he's talking about
is the actual lernian hydra the monster for
which hydra actually takes its name implying that
he's found a way to summon it from the multiverse
in the comics the hydra beast was the spawn of the
greek titan typhon there are greek gods inside the
marvel universe like russell crowe is going to
be playing a version of zeus during thor love
and thunder the hydra's mother was also one of the
children of the elder gods like cathone for those
of you wanting hercules to show up in the mcu one
of the 12 labors of hercules inside the mcu was to
slay this mythical hydra creature but that's the
comic book version the mcu version now because
this is all cannon to the mcu is that this is an
interdimensional being so i know a lot of people
were wondering if this was going to be like a
version of schumachorth no it is the mythical
hydra but schumacher is also an interdimensional
being with a lot of giant tentacles they do a
similar scene from the first captain america
movie where he can't get drunk because of the
super soldier serum peggy carter is also upset
that she can't get drunk anymore and enjoy whiskey
they have a brief moment sort of continuing that
theme of their dance together as bucky and howard
stark show up to take her and steve on the same
mission to hijack that hydra train from the first
captain america movie this time bucky is safe from
falling into the ravine by peggy carter who makes
a reference to his metal arm from the movie saying
you almost ripped my arm off so like i said in
this universe in this timeline bucky never becomes
winter soldier but the twist here the person that
goes down winds up being steve rogers in the iron
man armor suit the whole train itself is just
meant to trap steve rogers so the red skull can
steal the tesseract back from the hydra stomper
armor they have a joke about peggy torturing arnim
zola you do kind of wonder what she did to get
him to talk but he gives away all red skull's
plans allowing her to mount the rescue mission
they explain how he's going to bring the hydra to
conquer the earth or destroy it if that won't work
and when they break into the castle bucky says
you go high i go low that's another speech from
the first captain america movie red skull uses the
test rack then to open the portal summon the hydra
steve rogers steals back the hydra stomper armor
and in this universe the way red skull goes out is
that the hydra kills it just right after coming
out of the portal crushing him to death the way
they play it is that he's dead but we didn't see
the body so i guess you could theorize that he
survived somehow but i think they really want
you to think that he died because of all those
crunching sounds peggy grabs a nearby sword so
even though it's not actually excalibur i was
kind of hoping that it would be excalibur captain
britain the black knight both characters from the
king arthur mythology inside the marvel universe
have wielded excalibur so her being british
wearing the union jack having a shield it's kind
of like she's becoming a classic british knight
character she kind of becomes marvel's version
of brienne of tarth from game of thrones just
charging around swinging a sword howard stark
makes a joke about getting it on with hedy
lamarr who was a famous german actress at that
time i spent some time with her but she sure as
hell was not teaching me german the whole thing
with the hydra's cries driving everyone mad is
just one of its powers from the comics they also
explained that as it breaks into our dimension it
also physically starts growing larger and larger
and it'll just continue to grow until it consumes
entire continents after steve's iron man hydra
stomper armor runs out of energy peggy is forced
to physically push it back through the portal
herself they have that same speech from the end
of the first captain america movie you owe me that
dance yeah saturday night definitely happening
whereas captain america went into the ice which
they also referenced earlier in the episode
peggy carter disappears into the tesseract portal
but the crazy thing is that it transports her
through space time into the future 70 years to
the events of the first captain america movie she
winds up coming through that portal in that same
scene that loki did at the beginning of the first
avengers film when nick fury says please put down
the sword it's just a twist on his line to loki
saying please put down the spear after he showed
up with the scepter hawkeye is there both samuel
l jackson and jeremy renner are playing their
characters in the series they'll be in multiple
episodes and in the way that steve rogers went
into the ice but then became a legend in united
states history in world history and everyone
knew who he was in present day hawkeye also kind
of lets us know the same thing happened in this
universe where everybody kind of knows who peggy
carter is oh this is captain carter then they
have the speedrun version of the end of the first
captain america movie the post credit scene where
nick fury tells him the war ended 70 years ago
and he's in the year 2012. then they imply that in
her universe they form the avengers around captain
carter just like they did around steve rogers
in the main mcu universe then like i said that
outro speech that the watcher gives is directly
taken from the text of the what if comics that he
has in every single what if comic but even though
this is a really big deal next week's episode two
is going to be what if black panther became star
lord so it'll be much more guardians of the galaxy
we won't really start seeing a ton of the what
if main characters start crossing over with each
other meeting each other till the later episodes
but eventually they will all form up right now
this is the order of the episodes that we know
about so next week it's black panther becoming
star-lord then episode 3 is what if someone tried
to kill all the avengers before they became the
avengers episode 4 is the doctor strange episode
episode 5 might be the iron man episode because
they're kind of slowly moving forward in the
timeline episode 6 is the wakanda episode and
i think when we get to the later episodes we get
more to the ultron to the marvel zombies of it all
like the really crazy stuff like i said there are
nine episodes total if you spotted any other big
easter eggs in this episode that i didn't mention
in the video just write them below in the comments
my full what if episode 2 video will post next
week i do have a couple bonus videos planned
this week so make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss any of them if
there any big requests or big questions you have
just leave them in the comments below and i'll add
them to my future videos everyone click here to
learn what's going on with thanos during the what
if series and click here for my spider-man what-if
trailer video and learn what's going on with him
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next video!